[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 elle
a une ce soir l'avancée du M23 dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo la milice rebelle est à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de la ville de
Goma le facilitateur est africain
l'ancien président Kenya ou Kenyatta
s'est rendu sur place alors que les
combats se poursuivent à l'arme lourde
dans la région nous serons à Kinshasa
dans ce journal
La Côte d'Ivoire qui a annoncé une
réduction progressive de sa contribution
à la minusma la mission de maintien de
la paix de l'ONU au Mali une annonce
dans un contexte de tension entre les
deux pays la correspondance à Abidjan
dans un instant et puis 8 milliards
c'est le chiffre du jour 8 milliards
d'habitants sur Terre une population qui
a augmenté surtout sur le continent
africain nous ferons le point à la fin
de cette édition
le M23 qui se rapproche dangereusement
de la ville de Goma dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo de
violents combats ont éclaté hier entre
les rebelles et l'armée congolaise alors
que les initiatives de paix se
poursuivent l'ancien président kenyan ou
kenyata facilitateur de la communauté
des pays d'Afrique de l'Est s'est rendu
à Goma ce mardi pour tenter une
médiation écouter
nous devons arrêter avec cette guerre
ses enfants c'est maman c'est vieillard
qui ne savent pas pourquoi les gens se
battention
avec cette guerre et commençons un
dialogue
nous avons vu nos militaires en train de
fuir ils étaient très nombreux lorsque
nous avons vu ça nous avons eu peur et
on a commencé à fuir on a cru que
l'ennemi était en train d'arriver
nous sommes en train de fuir mais nous
ne savons pas où nous allons passer la
nuit que Dieu nous aide
à propos recueilli par notre
correspondant à gommage Justin à
kaboumba nous étions tout à l'heure avec
le correspondant de RFI et France 24 à
Kinshasa Pascal moulegua il revient pour
nous sur la situation sur le terrain
écouter
depuis 5 jours les rebelles jump 23
tente des conquérir la cité des kiboumba
une vingtaine km au nord de la ville de
Goma qui est le chef-lieu de la province
du Nord qui vous les combats se
poursuivre présentement dans les
hauteurs de la cité des kiboumba au pied
du volcan niragongo M23 tente de faire
sauter ces verrous qui donne accès à la
ville de Goma mais fait face à la
résistance de l'armée qui tient à les
repousser et reconquérir toutes les
zones
occupées l'armée met ainsi à
contribution son armée de l'air et ses
forces spéciales dans notre camp M23 est
accusé de bénéficier de l'appui de
l'armée rwandaise selon Kinshasa c'est
qui gallina des démentir d'importantes
cité comme Bouna Ghana retour au centre
sont toujours contrôlés par les
mouvements rebelles qui réclament un
dialogue avec les autorités congolaises
des autorités qui sont restés fermes et
qualifiés à M23 des groupes terroristes
avec lesquels on ne peut négocier et
mais en tout cas sur la ligne de front
l'intensité des combats a changé de
manière signific
et dans ce contexte de combat le
gouverneur militaire du Nord qui vous a
dû prendre la parole pour appeler la
population à garder son calme écouter
rumeurs faisant état de la présence
ennemie dans la ville de Goma
lesquels rumeurs
sont véhiculés par l'ennemi afin de
créer une panique générale
au sein de la population
je vous demande de rester calme
et des vagues librement à vos
occupations
je tiens
à vous rassurer que les forces
loyalistes
se comportent très bien sur le terrain
des opérations
et contiennent l'ennemi dans les auteurs
de
[Musique]
toutefois
je vous demande
de rester vigilant
et de résister à l'ennemi
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur la
situation dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo on en vient à
cette annonce de l'ambassadeur ivoirien
aux Nations unies la Côte d'Ivoire va
réduire progressivement ça a
contribution à la minusma la mission de
maintien de la paix au Mali cette
décision s'inscrit dans un contexte de
tension entre les deux pays après
l'arrestation en juillet dernier de 46
soldats ivoiriens Bamako accusé par les
autorités maliennes d'être des
mercenaires les précisions Abidjan de sa
diamant Joe
c'est la date du 15 novembre journée
nationale de la paix en Côte d'Ivoire
que les autorités ivoiriennes ont choisi
pour officialiser la nouvelle on apprend
dans un courrier envoyer aux Nations
Unies que la Côte d'Ivoire n'en verra
pas de nouvelles troupes au Mali et
qu'elle se donne jusqu'à août 2023 pour
retirer tous ses soldats présents sur le
territoire malien en août dernier la
Côte d'Ivoire avait déployé 425 soldats
dans le nord du Mali pour une mission de
12 mois cette mission sera donc la
dernière les soldats ivoiriens qui
seront retirés du Mali vont être
redéployés dans d'autres pays dans le
cadre des missions en zone de maintien
de la paix cette annonce intérieure dans
un contexte de tension entre le Mali et
la Côte d'Ivoire 46 soldats ivoiriens
sont toujours détenus au Mali depuis le
10 juillet ils sont accusés par Bamako
d'être des mercenaires des autorités
ivoiriennes ni ses accusations et elles
assurent que les soldats travaillaient
alors pour le compte de la minusma à ce
jour les le pays n'ont pas trouvé de
terrain d'entente pour la libération
malgré des multiples médiations dans
celles du président togolais et des
représentants de la CEDEAO
nord-est de l'actualité en bref et en
images le premier convoi d'aide médicale
depuis fin août qui est arrivé à mardi à
mekeler la capitale du Tigré en Éthiopie
une conséquence positive après l'accord
de paix conclut début novembre pour
mettre fin à la guerre dans cette région
rebelle du nord du pays une région
durement touchée par la guerre et la
famine
le détenu politique et politique égypto
britannique
la communauté internationale s'est
inquiétée de son sort alors que des
militants ont tenté en pleine COP 27
d'attirer l'attention sur la situation
des droits de l'homme en Egypte à l'abd
el-Fitr avait été condamné à 5 ans de
prison pour avoir simplement partagé un
poste pro-démocratie
et puis toujours en Égypte cette
manifestation d'activistes pour le
climat à 3 jours de la clôture de la
cop27 des dizaines de personnes ont
défilé à Charles melche pour demander
aux pays riches de cesser d'exploiter
des nouveaux gisements quasi
la population mondiale a franchi un
nouveau cap aujourd'hui selon l'ONU la
terre compte 8 milliards d'habitants il
faut savoir que plus de la moitié de
l'augmentation de la population mondiale
prévue jusqu'en 2050 sera concentré dans
8 pays dont 5 en Afrique l'Egypte
l'Ethiopie le Nigéria la République
démocratique du Congo et la Tanzanie
autre donnée importante selon l'ONU les
pays d'Afrique subsaharienne devraient
contribuer à plus de la moitié de
l'augmentation prévue jusqu'en 2050
c'est le cas du Nigéria coup de
projecteur avec Caroline lambolet
la plus grande ville au monde d'ici la
fin du siècle ça sera les gosses avec
plus de 15 millions d'habitants c'est
déjà l'une des plus grandes villes du
continent africain
pour ses habitants c'est plutôt une
mauvaise nouvelle
l'augmentation de la population au
Nigéria est une source d'inquiétude
ailleurs ce n'est peut-être pas le cas
car ils ont un gouvernement qui
fonctionne bien qui est bien structuré
la population est bien prise en charge
Léo Nigéria c'est tout le contraire
la population de l'Afrique subsaharienne
croient de 2,5% par an soit plus de
trois fois la moyenne mondiale c'est en
partie dû à la hausse de l'espérance de
vie mais pas que en moyenne les femmes
dans la région ont plus de quatre
enfants chacune deux fois plus que la
moyenne mondiale
dans certaines cultures on croit que
plus on a d'enfants plus on est fort
pour un homme si on a beaucoup d'enfants
c'est qu'on est un vrai homme et pour
une femme si on a beaucoup d'enfants
c'est qu'on est forte mais ce n'est pas
exactement la vérité donc il faudrait
qu'on se penche sur ça les gens doivent
être bien informés
parmi les pays les plus peuplés au monde
aujourd'hui le Nigéria devrait devenir
d'ici 2050 la troisième nation de la
planète
on part à présent à agadasso Niger vous
allez voir que cette ville considérée
comme l'un des joyaux culturels du pays
a beaucoup souffert de l'insécurité
pendant des années les agences de
voyages les hôtels et les guides ont pu
compter sur les milliers de touristes
qui venaient visiter la région 20 000
visiteurs par an en moyenne aujourd'hui
la situation est tout autre reportage
d'un rôle Gérard
[Musique]
Agadez plus de 30 ans ce sont écoulés
depuis la dernière rébellion touareg et
quinze années depuis que le terrorisme a
commencé à déstabiliser le Sahel de
tournant sécurité qui ont vidé la région
nigérienne de ses visites
chacun ses reconverti certains sont
devenus des transporteurs d'autres sont
devenus des orpailleurs d'autres encore
sont partis en Libye nous on a choisi de
rester ici dans la ville d'Agadez
la grande mosquée existe depuis plus de
500 ans et reste le symbole de la ville
même si ses portes sont la plupart du
temps fermé
plus loin dans la vieille ville les
anciennes baptistes d'architecture
traditionnels ont été sauvées par un
travail conjoint entre les habitants
d'Agadez et l'UNESCO mais l'absence de
touristes rend plus compliqué la
conservation c'est un savoir qui qui
voit se perdre bientôt même ça que tu
vois c'est très ancien mais on les a
retapées aux lézard est tapé mais sinon
avant c'est
parti Béchir ma main lui a créé son
propre restaurant à quelques pas de la
grande mosquée ses revenus ont beaucoup
diminué et malgré les aides
internationales dans la région il ne se
sent pas soutenu
ce serait bien que les organismes qui
arrivent dans la région nous aide enfin
les rares ONG qui viennent les ONG
pourrait nous aider à nous relever à
garder un revenu
dans la région comme Bachir les acteurs
du tourisme les plus qualifiés ce sont
tournés vers d'autres activités
[Musique]
petit pays au milieu des Caraïbes qui
fait face à une flambée de violence plus
de 150 gangs imposent leur loi face à un
état impuissant
massacre bal perdu enlèvement les
habitants sont les premières victimes de
la violence de ces gangs
qui se cachent sous leur lit pour se
protéger des balles qui performent les
droits de leur maison à l'insécurité
s'ajoute une crise politique la
légitimité du gouvernement en place et
contestée dans la rue nos journalistes
ont recueillis des témoignages
d'observateurs et authentifier des
dizaines de vidéos pour réaliser une
enquête inédite au cœur de la violence
des gangs haïtiens les observateurs
c'est avoir sur France 24 et France 24
com
regardez la météo avec les 175 ans
d'histoire et d'innovation gravés dans
vos Versailles
[Musique]
ces produits sont des dispositifs
médicaux